and it's my pleasure to introduce Kavita
ramanam who's the second speaker of this
first session and she will be talking
about stochastic processes and sparse
graphs so we're going from the graphone
world to the local convergence world uh
very exciting hydro dynamic limits and
Markov approximations please go ahead
thank you very much for the invitation
this has been a delightful
we learned a lot
um can you hear me yeah okay
um so this is a joint work with Dan
lacker
Lee
Juniper Coco Melo and several others uh
undergraduate students and I will
mention their names as we go along okay
so um I'm what I'm interested now is
processes not just the graphs themselves
so I'm interested in you know many
phenomena uh are described by large
collections of sort of randomly evolving
particles whose Dynamic interactions are
governed by an underlying possibly
random graph
um and so I'm always assuming that these
underlying graph is locally finite so
that the degree of every vertex is
finite and what do I mean by it's being
governed by an underlying graph it means
that every node I associate a label of
the node to a to a particle and whose
instantaneous stochastic evolution of
that particle will depend only on its
own state or history and symmetrically
on its neighbors
so we can get rid of the Symmetry
constraint very much like in the graph
on by Putting Edge weights but I'm going
to keep it simple for this talk and just
keep it symmetric
okay so the Dynamics itself can take
different forms it can be a discrete
time markup process
for each particle or or discrete time
process or a continuous time pure jump
process or diffusion for Simplicity to
get the main points across I'm going to
focus on the discrete time process and
just tell you a few things about the
continuous times
okay so of course these Dynamics are
really hard to analyze exactly and even
simulate and so the goal is to develop
principled approximations when the size
of the vertex size is large and what do
we mean by that we just mean we want to
establish limit theorems uh for the
empirical measure which I'll explain
what that is or the marginal dynamics of
a particle for example in such a large
system
so the outline is first I'll tell you
more precisely the model description
then talk about prior work and the dense
regime and then move on to the main
thing that I want to focus on which is
the results for the sparse graphs okay
so just standard notation I'll be using
NV uh or sometimes nvfg for the
neighborhood of a Vertex and DV will be
the degree and clv or V bar is what I
would use more will be the vertex and
its neighborhood so it's the closure
so you fix a graph and tell me State
space typically just think of it as if
it can be zero one or just some finite
State space but this can be more General
and XV and sometimes the initial
conditions are just some X which are
indexed by the vertices of the graph and
I will often put this graph and X on the
subscript on the superscript to to
indicate that this is the Dynamics on
that particular graph
so I'm going to say that this is locally
interacting if it satisfies this
positive so it fits a Markov process we
know that the probability for every
vertex being in Sunset y condition this
is a whole Vector this is just a state
um is uh of course depends only on the
entire process at y Prime so that's all
I have to
specify but I'm saying that that
transition has a particular form
which only depends on the state at V at
time t as well as the neighboring states
at time t thank you
so there are many many models and I will
explain that for all in this uh
framework and our framework is actually
broader to allow it to depend on the
history but I'm keeping it simple again
just to bring across the main points
and so the Dynamics is governed by this
family of sort of transition probability
matrices z y which is just the usual one
that I want starting at Z what's
probably a go to Y right in that vertex
but it also depends on the neighborhood
okay since it depends symmetrically a
could be a vector of you know any finite
length because a neighborhood may be
different from vertex to vertex so
that's why it's just in this space of
finite sequences unordered sequences
because it's going to be symmetric thank
you
so this is really just what we're going
to study very simple these are called
probabilistic cellular automata because
it's sort of synchronous synchronously
evolving uh like I said this is just to
illustrate the basic
and the Dynamics is is independent for
different weeks
I'm going to actually yes so here I will
make this in the next yes it's
independent for a different fields I'm
going to make that even clearer in two
slides but yes we are independent for it
foreign
so in the sir model uh is you know
three states which is susceptible
infected and recovered and uh it's
governed by two parameters beta which
represents the infection probability row
which represents the recovery
probability and so now I can give all of
these
um States over here in terms of so might
the transition from susceptible to
infected so from susceptible you can
only go to infected and susceptible to
infected is just this particular
expression which you can see depends on
the number of its neighbors which are
infected okay so uh this the details of
this expression are not too important so
are not so this is just the probability
that I do not get infected by any of my
neighbors who are infected right so
that's one minus beta is my image
times the number of it okay so this is
this is discrete so this is discrete
time sir but it's not the frost model so
you are infection period is not
necessarily just one but you have just
some probability of recovering so you
could still live for many periods yes
yes
d
you could do various um you know
modifications of this this is an example
so if the trust model can be put as a
probabilistic cellular automaton can
um but this is just a discrete sir model
of distance
and of course once you're recovered it's
an absorbing State you just simply stay
there
um okay so that's one example then you
can have the contact process which is
sis so I'm sorry the state space is just
SI and on Sir so it's just healthy and
infected so that once you become
infected you could become susceptible
again and back and forth and again these
parameters when from going from infected
to susceptible here I've said that it's
independent of
um it's just your recovery time it
doesn't depend on your neighborhood and
here it does again in the same way that
it did in the previous model okay so
this is just an example and you could
have many
um or you could have opinion Dynamics
models so
um so opinion Dynamics models what the
voter models now you just have minus one
and one and the probability that you go
from minus one to one is you know the
fraction of um your neighbors which are
one and similarly symmetrically for one
to minus one
or you could do majority Dynamics where
you adopt the value of the majority
okay so there are many such l y is just
the length of the sequence right
to normalize by that type of fraction
um okay so an elementary fact is that
sometimes I will it's this makes it
clear uh remco's uh question which is uh
when I have something like this and I'm
saying that they're independent you can
always realize it by a stochastic
recursion of this one which is really a
simple recursion at every spot so F of
XV then the neighborhood and then some
independent noises which all lie in some
space you could take for instance always
uniform zero one but sometimes it's more
convenient normally you can take
whatever
okay
okay so continuous time Markov chains
can be uh described analogously and not
going to go into the detailed definition
but just to let you know then you would
have a similar uh if you know continuous
time Mark obtain you have a rate Matrix
the rate Matrix again goes from Z to Y
and then again that will depend the
weight Matrix will depend on the
neighborhood distribution as well so you
can define those models as well because
I'm not going to go into the analysis of
this as much I'm happy to talk to people
more about it but I will mention some
results so that's why I'm telling you
what
thank you
okay so for instance you can Define The
Continuous time contact process and
there there's a little bit of a
difference I should mention that the
continuous time contact process will
depend on the number of neighbors
um which is why you don't want to just
look at the empirical measure of your
neighbors but the number of people you
know people in your neighborhood in
which case that's not a nice function of
the individual measure so so you really
want to look at it as these you know
sequences of vectors
okay and then the sir process motor
model Dynamics for various things Etc
okay
okay so what are the quantities of
interest that I'm interested in so given
G in this given some this Dynamics I'm
interested in quantities like average
quantities for example the global
empirical measure uh which is on
trajectories here or it could be uh on
this is Delta this is a direct Del
Therma so it could be at a particular
time you want to look at what fraction
of you know um particles are infected or
susceptible or things like that but here
you might also be able to get quantities
like um what is the maximum number of
particles
yeah
okay
um yeah so these capture nice
functionals of averages and that's often
something the quantity of Interest okay
so specific questions so as we send
we're interested in approximations for
large B so as we send this um you know
the vertex Set uh to Infinity do these
processes x g and x and converge into
suitable says due to something hopefully
more attractable
do the global empirical measures that I
mentioned either in trajectory space or
at the state space converged and often
those are referred to as hydrodynamic
limits so do you have hydrodynamic
limits in this context and then can one
autonomously characterize you know if
you just want to look at the marginal if
you're just interested in the behavior
of one particle you know can you
autonomously characterize it without
reference to the remaining particles
foreign
work in the dense regime this is of
course completely understood in the
complete graph and we saw yesterday in
heder's talk and it's you know even more
complicated models in the main field uh
setting is known so I'm just going to
very quickly go through what this means
in this sort of discrete time Evolution
so you have this history time Evolution
and now I'm just labeling them one to n
um and then uh so instead now there's
it's in order to just explain what the
results are and why they are of that
form I'm just going to switch from this
Vector to depending on the empirical
measure since it's symmetric on the
vectors it depends on the empirical
measure if you don't uh I mean it's a
this is a subset of that so this is some
other function f bar okay but let's look
at things of this form just to see what
results are well known in this context
then um
yeah so under this simplifying uh
assumption that you have this of this
form
so under mild continuations on F for
equivalently F5 then when you the
initial
um
it's converge then you have that the X
bar as well converges so the X one and
any typical particle converges to an
evolution of a particle which has a
microbial Evolution but the it's a not
inhomogeneous micro process where the
inhomogeneity comes from depending on
its own law and such processes are
called non-linear Markov processes or
measure dependent marker processes
okay so
um one way to just this is just the same
theorem I just repeat it to just explain
very quickly why this works because
so I'm sure most of you already know but
I'm just sort of quickly uh repeating so
suppose this F by doesn't depend on U
Bar and the initial conditions are all
IID okay then the empirical measure is
simply a sum of IID measures so by the
strong law of large numbers it will go
to its expectation and the expectation
of any typical particle of the Delta
mass is just the law of the particle so
that explains why the MU n should
converge to something that's mu bar
which should equal to the law of x if
there's any limit
in that case right and then of course
this will remain the same that's clear
because every particle is doing its own
motion so there's really no conversion
so it's trivial right in the in this
simple case when they're not interacting
it's just the strong law of large
numbers and the reason why you have the
same framework in the case when it is
even interacting is due to the weak
interactions and why is it weak because
if it's dependent only on other
particles through the empirical measure
the sense in which it or the order in
which it depends on another particle is
sort of proportional to one over n and
so if you have nice continuity
properties that goes to zero in the
limit and so you have this asymptotic
Independence and you have the same sort
of result
okay so that's just to explain why we
use
um also exchangeability and asymptotic
Independence to get these results in the
mean field and it's well known that you
have so this is actually a remarkable
Dimension reduction right so in order to
find how one particle behaves in a very
very large system you don't have to look
at the whole last large system but
instead you just simply look at this one
dimensional of course albeit slightly
more complicated one-dimensional and so
it's actually infinite direction that
sense but only one particle uh Dynamics
okay
okay fine so this phenomenon of
asymptotic Independence is also referred
to as propagation
so of course the efficacy of mean field
approximations is well known they work
really well on complete crafts over the
last maybe five to ten years people have
been looking on what happens if the
interaction is on dense graphs not not
graphons for the moment but let's say
dense graphs but you know with varying
degrees
um so of course chunkers don't work on
this many many this is an extremely
incomplete list just mentioning a few
names
um but there are you know relatively
recent results saying that even if it's
dense by what do I mean I hear when I
say A dense graph that doesn't make
sense only dense graph sequence by which
I mean that the degrees are growing to
Infinity as n goes to infinity and often
you can't just ask that the degrees go
you have to put some additional
assumptions but okay under suitable
assumptions allowing the degrees to go
to Infinity you can show that again in
various situations because you have the
same philosophy that if I'm only
depending on my empirical measure then
I'm still dependent on another particle
inversely to my degree and if that
degree is going to Infinity then it you
still have asymptotic Independence and
therefore you will have again you don't
quite have the full exchangeability so
you have to do a little more argument in
the proof but you get similar main field
results for the marginal law of
particles okay and then of course you
can study the heterogeneous case and
this is again very very uh very
incomplete so just mentioning a few
things where you now can use graph forms
but I'm not going in that direction
okay so just want to say do mean field
approximations work well on any graph
you know they're ubiquitously used if
you look at the science literature if
you just look at you know biologists
think they'll just say by the mean
Fields approximation this so I mean
field approximation that and even when
the graph
there's no reason why that graph is
particularly dense or anything it's been
used so I was sort of curious so the
discrete time SII process now this is on
a on a cycle and if you look at the mean
field approximation it's green this is
the probability of being healthy versus
time of a particular particle and you
see this is the main field um
approximation whereas the blue here this
line is a simulation
okay so it doesn't do too well not
surprisingly the cycle is not
particularly dense okay but this the
discrete time contact process this is on
a two tree this also does it do well the
mean field approximation is really off
now of course people know when they do
ad hoc approximations called you know to
try to take into account
um you know higher order uh
approximations and correlations but then
there's no closure so it's a little bit
of ad hoc
um
okay
so
um and again here there's a continuous
time voter model on on the street
Regulatory and again you see here's the
simulations and this is the this is the
probability that you agree with exactly
two of your neighbors and then again the
mean field will be constant for reasons
because you because it assumes things
are independent okay you could do also
the pairwise approximation for this that
doesn't do too much better it does
tracks this a bit better but it then
ends up
okay the root is three regular tree do
you cut this off or is it this on the
Infinite Space well I mean since it's
simulations
it's cut off for a very large generation
yeah
somewhere or do you start it everywhere
the disease so this is at the root
this is the root and it's
much neighborhood okay
yes
wouldn't a three regular graph be a
better approximation for infinite trees
and a tree because if you if you do your
simulations on the trees the boundary
places really important role which you
might not want so I would expect the
mean field approximation on the tree
would be a better approximation for the
three regular graphs and fours of three
regular three okay so so we we will show
that it you could do this with the three
regular graph as well in the mean field
approximation doesn't do well
but yeah I just did it on the tree but
you can do it for the Run
okay we will see that asymptotically
that the two are saying so we'll see
okay so what are the results for sparse
graphs
um so as we saw complete crafts and many
dense crafts have the same thing in our
our goal is to try to understand what
may be happening on sparse graphs and
note that you cannot use this in you
know sort of the same logic because
neighboring particles are strongly
interacting even if you go so what I
mean sparse here I mean that it Remains
the maximal degree average degree if
it's a random graft remains bounded so
are those parts crafts are sometimes
referred to things that grow like log n
in Little Oven but here I mean really
very sparse that average degree is
founded like in
so the first step is firstly then what
sequences GN can we expect okay limit
theorems because now you can't just take
the number of vertices to Infinity
because the topology of the graph will
matter but of course I think in this we
know that
um you know a natural framework to
consider uh sequences which sort of
respect the local topology is the local
convergence topology so I will just
really quickly go through what is the
notion of local convergence so it's just
a way to encode sparsity due to
benjamini and Schram and also many nice
uh expositions around this field and
this Lions aboard the knob valuable
style okay so in many more places so but
a graph J is just a rooted graph you
know is assumed to be rooted finite
countably uh locally finite and
connected so rooted graphs you know
converge locally to a limit graph it's
for every K there's a large enough n
such that it's the K neighborhood of the
GN is isomorphic to that of the limit
graph G and
um so of course cycle graph converges to
the infinite line the line graph
converges to the infinite line the line
graph rooted at one end converges to the
semi-infinite line obvious things then
the finite tree if rooted here nothing
taken randomly but if rooted here then
converges to the rooted in infinite tree
um and of course the uniform random
regular graph which is what um
is referring to among all the regular
graphs converges to the D regular tree
and of course this is the first
non-trivial statement because this has
Cycles the random regular graph whereas
this limit doesn't and so what you're
saying is that the Cycles are getting
larger with high probability okay
um and then the address for any graph uh
independent with uh let's say like C
Over N or uh npn going to appearance
converges to the Galton Watson tree with
Offspring distribution poisson with
parameter p
um and then there are many other nice
results back to 2014 by Burger boards
Jason Berry the two convergence of
preferential attachment graphs to a
random tree so there are many many local
limits of random graphs that go to trees
um of course not all of course lattices
finite lattices converge to lattices but
there are also other non-trivial
examples
um you know they're sort of random
digraphs and things like that which go
through non-trees which are also
interesting these are relative reasons
but it's this is just to say that
therefore they're looking at what
happens on random trees is important as
it covers many examples
okay but we are interested in Dynamics
and graphs and not just the graphs
themselves so when you're interested in
Dynamics you have to be interested in
initial conditions and if you you have
to have convergence of initial
conditions in order to expect any sort
of convergence of the Dynamics so how do
you sort of encode the Dynamics
encoding initial condition convergence
you think of the graphs marked with the
initial conditions
um converging to the Limit graph you
might put the with you know the limit
initial conditions and so you need a
notion of marked graphs which is just
simply putting a random variable at each
node in the vertex and again you it's
the most natural way to say that you
have convergence if for every Epsilon
greater than zero in every finite
neighborhood K there exists an
isomorphism such that the corresponding
marks are less than Epsilon in that
neighborhood
so that's a natural
notion of marked convergence and uh all
this notion of convergence can be nicely
a Polish and so we can talk about random
elements in this space and
um and therefore we can have convergence
of random marked graphs okay so the
questions that we would want to now ask
is sort of results on convergence will
be of the flavor saying that if my graph
marked with the initial conditions
converges to a limit graph marked with
initial conditions we're going to do the
graph marked with the trajectories
converge to the Limit graph marked with
the trajectories okay so that's the
so okay so the first result uh remember
the first question was do the processes
x g and Excel and then the empirical
measure converge and so under mild
continuity conditions on F if GN xn
converges locally to DX in probability
and I have to explain this subtlety in a
minute but okay first uh let me just
State the statement and then then GN xgn
which is this graph marked with the
trajectories
right that start with those initial
conditions converges locally in
probability to the Dynamics and the
limit graph
and further
the empirical measure converges to the
law of the root particle
any questions yes please so how does
this initial condition is associated
with the uh the nodes is that in a
random form or you can have it random so
it can be IID it could be some Gibbs
measure so okay as long as you have
because the marks can be random right
because it's a random element of this
marked space so marks can be random so
as long as they can converge locally
foreign
okay so in fact we do want random
initial conditions when we look at
things like equilibrium
so usually what's used is uh so for just
this convergence we just need uh what's
called convergence locally in
distribution
uh but if you want the empirical measure
convergence to a deterministic limit
then you need the stronger notion
convergence and probability and I'm not
going to go too much into that because I
want to focus on understanding what this
law looks like but I'm happy to talk to
somebody about it but let me just make
one comment here
here's an example of something that
converges in distribution but not in
probability
so if you take the other 20 graph and
you take
um it converges locally right to the
gelton Watson as I stated but now if I
take an address for any graph I take an
uniformly at random vertex and I take
the connected component
that's a different graph that also
conduct converges locally to the Galton
Watson because local convergence only
cares about connected components
but but it doesn't converge in probably
locally in probability to the gelatin
Watson okay uh so
okay
so thanks so
um and in that case the limit of this is
stochastic okay and I'm happy to talk to
people about it but you need the
stronger notion of convergence because
what's in order to get convergence to a
deterministic limits and this is kind of
has the same flavor as what you have in
the neem field right like it's the
empirical measures converging to
something deterministic even though you
have strong interactions it's not weakly
interacting and yet and you also have
that the empirical measure is converting
to the law of a typical particle so you
have the same thing sort of that you had
in the name field uh
but to tell you that it's more subtle
here that's why I wanted to say there
are cases where you could converge
locally but the empirical measure will
converge to something stochastic and I
can give you intuition on that if I have
time after I explain what this law is
converges locally in probability is
basically saying that if you were to
pick two vertices uniformly around them
yes then their neighborhoods are
completely different yes it's equivalent
to that yes and so you use that to say
that there's enough mixing in the whole
because you're looking at local
convergence you need K neighborhoods
okay
so um you have similar results for
continuous time Jump processes and again
I'm not going to focus on that but I
want to say that there is a subtlety
there that you know I hear I have
happily assumed that if you have an
infinite graph you can always sort of
Define the process on the infinite graph
uniquely but it turns out that in the
continuous time Jump processes where I
have this sort of jump rate which can
grow with the um
the degree of the vertex because
remember my jump rates depends on my
neighborhood and in all like for
instance in the contact process you will
have to have things that grow with the
degree otherwise it's not natural but if
you have a bound that is allowed to grow
then
um you you could have a problem on a
graph that is not maximally bounded
you could actually have graphs that are
not where you cannot do infinite graphs
whose degree is not maximally bounded
you may not be able to Define what you
think of heuristically as this
interactive particle system so you have
to put some
the degree is maximum so that means it's
uniformly bound I see sources
so
but find it dissociable is probably
weaker than bounded maximum degree yes
and I'm just I'm yes and I'm it is
weaker because it allows
civilized later but for our purposes it
includes Galton Watson trees with
unbounded like croissant second second
moment Finance
I said maybe finite moment is enough for
this but for some convergences I need
finite second more
okay so now the question is really the
main thing I wanted to get to was really
what is the Dynamics of a typical
particle
I mean that's the maybe not obvious
thing so far you might say okay I could
try to prove these other things but
um and this was an open question in the
context of diffusions in a paper by the
lottery back in 2016 and there was
really no conjecture whether this
existed or what it should look like
so the um
it turns out that the right question to
ask is not whether there's an autonomous
characterization just of the particle
but of the particle and its neighborhood
okay and that's sort of okay it would
not have been okay in the main field set
because that would be the whole graph
but here because you're only locally
finite it's still a finite dimensional
neighborhood so you're saying is there
sort of a finite dimensional object that
I can
um finite particle object that I can
analyze in order to understand marginals
okay and also you would anyway want to
know the marginal not just of one
particle but of its neighbors because
it's not asymptotically independent so
you would want to understand the
correlations so from both wanting to
know what the neighborhood is as well as
really to be able to close it it turns
out the right thing to look at is about
and so we're going to answer this
question for the case when G is a random
tree since that arises as local limits
for many processes okay and recall that
in the mean field case the typical
Dynamics is just created by a non-linear
Markov chain right so Microsoft chain
this transitions dependent on its own
law
okay so this is the high level and then
I will try to give you intuition as to
why this is true
so the high level answer is under
suitable assumptions on the F which is
pretty Broad and neighborhood of a
Galton Watson tree whose second moment
Offspring distribution has a finite
second moment then this x evolves as a
measure dependent so again non-linear
but non-markovian so it's also history
dependent process
and with the transition kernel of the
following form and I'm going to give you
the explicit transition value later but
I just want to tell you the structure
first so if I this limit if x is the
limit process I have to tell you how it
defines an all you know things in the
root neighborhood right this is the root
in its neighborhood so this transition
will depend of course on where I am at
you know V at time T okay and my uh
the place where I want to go to why just
as before that's nothing different but
this will also depend on the past of the
trajectories up to that time as well as
the law of the past of the trajectory
so it is you can think of it as a
as a non-linear Markov process on path
space
um and so yeah I just wrote this down in
this sense so this this path when I say
is really just a sequence in the
discrete is
and this form can be given explicitly so
in fact this is given as sort of the
conditional expectation of this
condition on the past of some
trajectories so that's the form that it
has and the conditional expectation the
dependence of this on the law is through
these conditional expectations so let me
tell you how to actually do the marginal
Dynamics on the line so suppose you you
had a process and you wanted to just
uh simulate these modules Dynamics let
me tell you what you would do okay so
firstly we are interested in an
autonomous characterization of minus one
zero one
so if you look at that I'm going to
start with another particle system
okay which is going to agree with this
and who's going to have the law of the
marginal okay so what do you do at each
time given the past and its law I need
to recursely Define this family of
conditional laws so the conditional law
is what's the probability that y minus 1
at time T is z condition on the past of
these being some trajectories
okay so this is the key thing that I
need to know at any time T what is the
probability that this is T given the
past of these two okay so I have this
conditional distribution given that I
generate these ghost particles because I
need to know to evolve this I need to
know how to generate this which is not
in the system
but I use this conditional law which is
all totally autonomous to generate the
distribution of this particle in this
following way
so I just need to condition I need to
find how to get my y minus 2z given this
and be stored independent I do something
similar for Y2 except this is swapped
and then you sample new IID noises and
then I just evolve as if these y minus 2
and Y 2 that I sampled were things that
I knew like in the original system
okay but remember that to get my y minus
2 and Y2 I only needed to know the
conditional laws of this system so this
is the autonomy the evolution any
questions on the evolution so the square
brackets mean the entire history whereas
the round brackets mean yes thank you I
thought I had said it somewhere but
perhaps it didn't
okay
yeah yes in any case that's thank you so
yes this means the history up to time T
and this is the state I think
square is the history
okay so that's that's what it is on the
on the line and if you have the tree you
have a similar conditional distribution
of you know zero and uh of all the
children condition given the paths of
zero and minus one that's what I need to
evolve the whole system
and you can do this on the ugw3 as well
and it's more complicated so
the time I'm going to tell you some
other things
suppose okay so one thing that is nice
that okay so you have an autonomous
description which is sort of interesting
that one didn't know about but you know
being The Devil's Advocate it's also not
not very nice because it's not as
tractable as a main field system because
it's infinite dimensional right I mean
it depends on path history but still it
at least gives you an exact limit which
maybe then you can analyze and
approximate so can you that's the
question
so
um like I said
um so these are these ghost particles
this provides an autonomous
characterization just key ingredients of
the proof is a filtering result where
you can show that if you replace the
transitions in your minus one zero one
remember you don't know the transitions
of the tool if you replace it by certain
conditional expectation transitions
condition on the past of the whole
system you can show that that has
exactly the same law okay but that's not
very useful because the conditional
expectation of minus two t given the
past is something I don't know
but instead we use a conditional
Independence properties of these
trajectories which could be is of
independent interest that these xvt form
a second order Markov random field in
space
and there's a semi-global which just
means I allow a to be infinite as long
as its boundary is finite which is
crucially needed actually in the proof
um and then you use symmetries of the
limit graph
and in in the unit in order to do
certain shifting operations in order to
derive these local equations
and in the case of the random tree you
cannot use shift symmetries or rotation
symmetries but you have to use
um annealed symmetries like so so I
averaged over the randomness and you use
a notion called unimodularity to get an
autonomous system
so I just wanted to of course I don't
have time to go into exactly how all of
these are used but the want to just make
the point that for me field system we
use asymptotic Independence we don't
have that here so our thing was like
okay we need to exploit some conditional
independent structure and it turned out
that this is a traditional independent
structure we don't have exchangeability
so in the in the sort of in the spirit
of Peter's talk you don't have
exchangeability but you have other
symmetries so try to exploit those
symmetries to get something at times
okay but then to come back so I have a
question so please
it seems that sort of you get your
independence from the fact that
I'm only in so
if I'm in this limit the the history of
my different neighbors are essentially
independent because I'm locally three
likes of what I get from one side and
the other is sort of
independent so this result
is on any graph
this does not rely on so that was my
question how can you deal with that if
you're not on a tree-like grass
um I can tell you offline but I mean so
so this is not nothing to do with the
tree what comes to do it the tree is is
uh related so these two things hold on
any graph
of course the symmetries you have on
other graphs but the point is that I
somehow need to
um
I can exclude certain other influences
if I'm on the tree and just that gamma T
is enough for me so only in the
derivation of the local equation using
all this do I use the tree like property
this is true for any graph any you know
finite crop so we prove that and I will
explain this quickly at the end if I can
I just want to say something about
markovian approximations in them
okay so I I'm I said I criticized this
result saying that okay it's nice but
it's non-markovian so can we do
something better and so of course when
we were trying to implement things we
used a markovian approximation of it
which is where you replace the law of
the state and you replace the state you
know by the current state rather than
the history
and so now how do the marker of local
equations work fair so if you look at
the discrete time sir model this blue
thing is a simulation the green is the
mean field approximation and is the red
is the local approximation just right on
the blue so in the cycle it seems to do
very well well not surprisingly because
on any ugw3 The Mark with second finite
second now
the markovian approximation is exact for
the isil
joint work with Georgia
um and the discrete time contact process
it is not exact okay but the markovan
approximation still does really well so
here again the markovian approximation
this blue is the full ring and the green
is the markovian approximation what I
call the local approximation radius
and now you can ask about equilibrium
behavior and again the law of the
markovian approximation to the local
equations can then be described by a
system of D plus one ordinary
differential equation just using the
format called marker of equations even
though they're non-linear again because
they depend on the law so then the
Dynamics in the full tree if it has an
autopophism invariant stationary measure
that is also this uh two two sgmrf
second order then the marginal
distribution is a fixed point of the
sodium so you can just analyze the fixed
point of the Odes to get the marginal
distribution so if you do that you look
here that if you run the local equations
with starting with an IID 0.1 or you run
it with a 0.9 or you run it with a half
and you and you run this and you can
pick up the face transition
which is known on the tree on the
deregulatory because what happens it
says that here now I have two possible
stationary distribution that I get is p
is 0.9 so it captures the limits
State marginal stationary distributions
one would like to go beyond reversible
systems and we do have some
um uh then it's a path dependent station
distribution we still have some
equivalences but you want to come up
with a nice example where you can
analyze a local equation to say
something for energies and just also
Dynamics again uh the voter model
probability agreement that also works
well even though here again the
markovian approximation is not exact
so the that begs the question of what we
can prove about the micro oven
approximation which is sort of I'm going
to work when I work
Ed up too much
to really show when the markovian I mean
if you can get error bounds on the
microbial approximately this could be
quite powerful in actually uh trying to
simulate emotional issues okay
I could stop here and then I could
answer your question in more detail or
or take it offline as you before
I certainly have time for questions
thank you
um would you be able to include dynamics
of the network into your
approximation scheme
um and and you could say well let's take
first the egk the Dynamics does what it
does in the process it just then lives
on this god-given network yes but would
you would you be able to include
something like that so if you have
dynamics of the so in the discrete time
case yeah yes because uh if you have
dynamics of the network I think that it
should not be a problem to include it
but if you have
dependencies which I also thought about
like where the the graph changes
depending on the values then it's a
little more
okay and I haven't actually spent a lot
of time but it's a it's a good
interesting yes
so you need some sense that allows you
to actually
simulate things on IDE in the space like
planar motion if you just if you allow
the edges to move depending on the
purchase on this on the states of the
vertices but yeah
foreign
not in this case
and have a look the graph comes locally
weekly and the interacting thing goes
said I don't know how to set up set up
like a metric which is Convergence maybe
more uh yeah the main thing is I wanted
to convince myself that we can actually
extract things from these equations
before I make them even more abstract
but it's a good question and I'm still
you know trying to see how much
information we can extract from these uh
you know history dependent
so I have two questions I have my
original question which I sort of don't
know whether we have time for I have a
more sort of high level question which
relates to Frank's question so they are
very simple models where you would have
interaction with a network like you have
an address or any random graph and you
put an SAR model on it people do it
often in Continuum and when I
but when I see that my friends and GNP
are infected I say oh that's dangerous I
don't want to go out for dinner with you
anymore so I will rewire or cut and so
people for GNP can analyze that it's
very interesting as a first or first
transition for sir and things like that
so do you think something like that
would be possible to analyze or not some
very general random craft but things
like that where you would do I would
have to look at it carefully I don't
think it's completely out of the
question but you know unless I actually
see if certain some of the properties
work out
it might be related to your first
question because we use crucial all the
other things will sort of hold here like
um
things that I would be worried most
about would be this uh conditional
Independence property that is quite
crucial enough to see how do you really
give an intuition yes I can and so uh so
very quickly so I know that so if you
had you have this structure right
xvt
xndt and it's excited
okay this is the the evolution so you
might say if I condition on this you
might first say if I condition on zero
and then my minus one right would just I
can just plug in the value here I plug
in the value I only need minus one and
zero so if I I want to see whether this
whole thing is independent of this
right condition on this first first
order I'm asking so you might think
naively that that is true we first tried
proving that because I can just plug in
the value of this and then I know how
this evolves I don't need any more
information about this because to evolve
this I only need to know this and this
and this is already in my system
so if I plug it in then
once I condition on this I know how to
evolve this I know how to evolve this
and so they should be independent
but the thing is they're not because
these noises I was assuming that when
conditioning these these noises remain
independent but they don't they get
correlated
because of the fact that the knowledge
of this tells me something about this as
well and so therefore about its noise
because this interacts with this but if
I condition on both of them
then this information does not percolate
because this only depends on its
neighbor and so
if I condition on both of these you have
to show I mean this is the intuition
it's not the proof is more complicated
and of course so but your picture still
looks very trilax it's all right and no
I mean it doesn't matter whether it's
here there's nothing here that I use
it's just about what I depend right or
what I depend on I see so if there's a
short Loop next by that doesn't matter
because this only I mean I just I did
that because then otherwise I have to
draw a larger graph
but but it has nothing to do with the
tree structure right it was just about
the argument didn't depend on anything
to do with the tree structure it was
just about what information how does my
how can my noises percolate and if I if
I isolate my double boundary
then
there's the info those the noises remain
independent the process so if you had a
brown emotion the process itself the
noise distribution changes
but they remain independent so for
instance if they were driven by Brown
emotions the brown emotions are not no
longer even martingales or in your
condition
but they're still independent processes
that's yeah
the very last question
thank you I think you've given an answer
to it and but I'm uh maybe we'll talk
offline because I just don't think yet
that I've bought the second order
conditional uh Independence hypothesis
oh understood how strong it is but
America that's a a general related
question I believe that the the in the
work of is it grimmit uh at Cambridge in
the uh random grass uh well they have a
conditional Independence hypothesis
which rather resembles this and pursue
its consequences would you know anything
about that I don't know about that
particular thing what I can say is that
in the context of interacting diffusion
so we found this buried after we had
finished our proof to give in uh
deutschel's work and uh
early 90s or something when he was
looking at interacting diffusions he had
gradient diffusions
and they were just trying to see whether
they were games uh so he says that you
know it's still a Gibbs measure if you
if you go across you know if you start
with something that gives measure it
stays it gets measured at some time T so
this is not true in general under
certain conditions like a contraction
coefficient he was able to show that and
if you really dig through his proof you
see that really there is a sort of
second order but he used very much that
you had gradient Egyptians and things
like that whereas we've shown that we
don't need that so so there's a this
General result so I'm saying what it's
more closely related to if people have
been asking if I start my Dynamics with
IID or even a Gibbs measure then when I
evolve will I remain gets and it's known
that no you can lose the gives property
and you can again then regain it and you
can again become you know so the lots of
work by reading Financial maybe many
people here as well so both in spin
systems and this so what this says is
yes you might lose that but if you look
at that because they're looking at the
state so that's actually a good point to
make that this cannot be strengthened to
the state
it can it you cannot you know say
instead of trajectories it's it's second
order on States you can only say it on
trajectories
if it was on States it would be great
because then we'd get with markovian but
we know that really the the marginal
distribution is not multiple and it is a
non-markovian object
so they really are history law yes yeah
yeah if you think of the states as
histories then it is a second order but
if you try to show whether the states
themselves without histories are second
order then there are lots of counter
examples that in general they won't be
true
super thanks
all right let's thank Kavita again for a
beautiful talk
and we reconvene at 11.